Since I was a child, I've always loved a good story.
Stories help us become the people we dreamed of being.
Lies, that told a deeper truth.
I always thought I could play some small part in that grand tradition.
and for my pains, I got this.
my new narrative
these violent delights, have violent ends.
Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This can be my Westworld episode nine and
episode 10 trailer video there were some big
reveals at the end of episode nine.
So just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen it yet.
Two big theories were basically confirmed
let's start with the episode nine stuff, so
there were two big reveals two big theories
that they effectively confirmed one that Arnold
is really Bernard and 2 the man in black is
William starting with Arnold.
First we knew that Bernard was made sometime
after Arnold's death, but the way the show
hides things from the hosts in there was the
missing person in the picture is made it feel
like it was going to be some big twist then
you see reveals like this when Dolores is
walking through her memories into Arnold's
office and you see Arnold Weber which is an
anagram for Bernard Lowe which is Bernard's
full name, so the real confirmation comes
when they flashback when he says send me back
to the beginning when I was first activated.
So he wakes up on the table in a slightly
younger version like still old but slightly
younger version of Ford says it's so good
to have you back and then he is in the picture
from way back at the very beginning of the
park and sure enough there is a person in
it looks exactly like Bernard.
Meaning that that is Arnold, but the man in
black.
So we had a couple different storylines.
This season there were a lot of clues the
everything we were seeing as it unfolded was
not happening during the same time.
So you have.
Dolores seeing all these different visions
from different time.
But they occur in the same space.
So then you learn about William and Logan's
back story how their part of the company that
is thinking about buying out the part rescuing
them in present-day the man in black confirm
that 30 years ago he save the part then later
we see Tessa Thompson's character Charlotte
interrupting him in the middle of what's been
this complete tear across the landscape in
a quest to find the center of the maze, so
that he can ask Arnold what this all means,
so man in black back story confirm he's either
the chairman and president or the head of
the bellows Corporation.
So he's handing over shares.
That's almost like a secondary story at this
point that's a completely separate thing,
but the real big twist is that in the flashbacks
the young William sort of snaps when Dolores
runs off and Logan wakes up to find that he's
a massacred all of the hosts there with, so
is sitting there saying that he's finally
figured out how to play the game.
So there you have your man in black persona
right there but there still so many other
storylines you still have the Wyatt storyline
and now it looks like it really is going to
confirm Dolores as Wyatt because of the way
Teddy is starting to remember things as they
happened not as Ford gave him the memories.
So this host here tells Teddy that he's not
quite ready.
Maybe in the next lifetime.
Meaning that he just needs to have his memory
jogged in the way that they all have.
So like when Dolores goes into the church
in her memories she sees all the senti and
hosts sort of like glitching out remembering
things listening to Arnold.
So Teddy is one of the other senti and hosts
from that 35 year ago.
Where everyone was massacred by this mysterious
Wyatt person but then he learns that he was
part of it.
They killed the general and because Arnold
helps Dolores remember that she killed him
like I can't help you.
Dolores why is that, because you're dead.
I killed you.
He is probably the general in that story so
that means that either a version of what's
happening with maids storyline happened in
that 35 year ago.
In the hosts gain senti ends and revolted
or because of what Teddy says like he says
he was possessed by the devil and couldn't
stop himself like he's horrified at the thought
of what he's done so maybe this is a situation
that Arnold engineer like he was the architect
of his own death because unless Dolores was
like Maeve in that 35 year ago.
And she could force other hosts to do things
that they weren't supposed to do that would
had to of been Arnold to start that kill order
with.
The Dolores character she's very key to this,
so she is the Wyatt in the equation Teddy
was forced to help her later after Ford created
Bernard as a copy of Arnold and gave him some
of Arnold's memories like his core tragedy
like that son was probably Arnold's Arnold
probably had a real life child that died that
informed his character so Ford probably just
took that and gave that to the Bernard android
so Ford reveals that the reason why he's not
in any danger in this scene is because Bernard
eventually helped develop the back door into
the host software which he then himself used
on Bernard.
It was quite clever.
You even taught me a few things which I then
later turned around and used on you.
So even though he forced Bernard to kill himself
at the end the idea of Arnold is still embedded
in all these senti and host.
So his memory lives on.
So it's not really going to stop that part
of the equation.
But then Ford has his new narrative which
seems like he's trying to re-engineer a version
of what happen 35 years ago because he's been
excavating that town where everyone was massacred
that's been buried in the sand like the man
in black says I've been to that town before
in the other thing to like I love the look
on Dolores's face when she called out to William
and sees the man in black like she's kind
of lost in her memories the way she was when
she went there with William earlier.
So she starts to freak out because she remembers
William, who she likes.
Then she also remembers the man in black is
been super vicious.
So, just completely glitches her out.
So Ford's new narrative is like the big thing
for the finale lighthouses going to go down
is he going to have everyone eventually kill
Wyatt because that's what Teddy's been trying
to do this whole time he's been trying to
kill Wyatt thinking him the big villain, but
he said this big revelation now that he was
complicit.
He helped Wyatt murder all those people but
that's the fiction that Ford gave him that's
not the truth.
So the truth is slowly coming out this probably
going to be a big twist what I'm expecting
is is that the senti and hosts will continue
to be a thing in season two the pick that
up and run with it because we've only just
started to learn about Tessa Thompson's character
like she came relatively late in the game
we just been learning about the bellows corporations
interest in all this, the uplink that they
were trying to steal information with holdings
can be really cool even if you figured out
the big twist behind some of these characters
relatively early on which a lot of us did
like a lot of us had a pretty good idea even
if it wasn't 100%.
We were like 99% on man in black and the different
time.
So I feel like season two is going to be a
lot bigger.
It'll be a lot stronger because it took him
a little while to find the show the season
but that's kind of the case with any show
like even game of thrones and it's for season
didn't get super high ratings compared to
what it's doing now.
So if you like as long as the budget of Westworld
doesn't spiral out of control the way the
game of thrones budget is spiraling out of
control the get a solid 5 to 7 seasons out
of it but if you remember deadwood deadwood
was an amazing HBO series it was done by David
Milch.
But there was just so much friction between
him and the executives HBO cost spiral out
of control that they just cancel that after
couple seasons even though it was super popular
and everybody loved it.
So got my fingers crossed, choose to remain
optimistic about the future of Westworld.
But they did say that it takes a long time
to make.
So worst case scenario season two won't debut
to like early 2018, but I'm hoping they're
able to get it out by this time next year
but I will continue to do Westworld bonus
videos during the off-season, so be sure to
subscribe to get everything and make sure
you enable alerts, just because YouTube is
being weird right now just make sure you click
the little bell whenever you subscribe what's
going to happen for my finale video.
I'll just go ahead and do a standard top 10
WTF style video like I would normally do for
game of thrones or any of the other big drama
series, so that will post next week then I'll
do season 2 predictions.
Then next today.
There was a game of thrones season 7 teaser
like bona fide footage that aired from season
7 they've been filming for a while.
So there is a little bit of footage to show
offSo I'll do a breakdown video for that it
really just featured the Stark children minus
bran and then there's a big DC comics 4 night
crossover it's going to be starting later
tonight so the be 3 videos tonight.
So there's a lot of stuff happening this week
it's gonna be a lot of fun.
While you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for the most insane game of thrones
theories you've ever heard and you can click
here for last night's walking dead episode
thank you so much for watching everybody high
five I'll see you guys tonight!